screen, click on stack and again click on stack mode and enable full screen mode in
below options. So, this will show you the full screen mode of the center. Please put
your queries in Q&A. So, please be assured that if professors are unable to attend all
your queries in Q&A session, it will be answered and approved in our discussion room. The raw
recording session will be available at the end of the day and the editor recordings will
be available on Monday that is the day after tomorrow. The assignment availability for the
week 14 assignment will be enabled at 2 p.m. and week 14 assignment submission deadline
on 25th of May 2025 Sunday till 11 p.m. and solution for the assignment will be available
on 26th of May that is on Monday. Today we have a quiz 13. So, we will be quiz 13 will
be available today Saturday 17th of May 2025 between 5 p.m. till 7 p.m. the duration of
the quiz is 30 minutes. Next topic, fronting with open sources LLMS. If you face any issues
during the quiz, attending the quiz, please reach out to us in 4.tcsionhab.tcs.com/service-stats.
So, they will help you out in case of any issues we found. The results for the assessment
that is quiz will be available at 9 p.m. the same day. So, to view the marks obtained click
on mark attempts taken it will show the status of the cells. So, they are trained to update
yourage profile on that already we have given. So, in case of any issues please reach out
to us in 4.tcsionhab.tcs.com. So, thank you. So, over to you.
Thank you so much. Thank you very much. I hope the screen is visible. Yes, it is visible.
So, good morning everyone. My name is Vishal and today I will go over some details on practical
image and language generation models. So, all of you have by now become familiar with
various image generation models and language generation models or even text image models.
But those practical systems are far more different than what you would see in say like the research
literature and it has gone through multiple iterations of improvements after which we
are in this stage where you have such useful applications based on this technology. So,
we will try to understand how the research has moved through different iterations as to
what the original proposal was and how did the researchers modify them to come to this
current stage where like they perform as well as they do now. So, let us first take a talk
of fire we started at. So, this slide shows the progression of how image generation has
improved over the time and the current wave on which we are at, this started around the
2014 with VA's and GANs and you can see like the first version of this was not even the
first paper but the image qualities that we used to get around that time was something
like on the left. It was very grainy, it was not able to handle the color and also like
it was not complex either. So, it was just like one face image and you could generate
such simplistic images only either digits or faces things like that. But compared to that
you come to 2018 and beyond like this is major news most recent versions and you can see
the amount of detail in these images and this is like extremely different from 2014 and
now it is almost indistinguishable from real like photo taken by camera. So, how like what
enabled this thing. So, you might be familiar with GANs or VA's the original architectures
but how do they come to make them so effective in practice that is what we will try to look
at today. And the same story kind of holds for text generation also text generation or
text understanding or text image any application that involves text for that matter. So, this
like wave also started for text around 2013 and so, we started seeing various neural network
for deep learning models which are very effective at doing very specific tasks in the period
of 2013 to 2018 and 19. And after that we kind of had like within few years we had the breakthroughs
of GPT models GPT3 models and then we have so many different models like Lama mid-journey
all these things. Who can now process any general takes general instruction beyond any
specific task definition. So, like this also has its own independent story which is slightly
different from what you see in the image domain and we will try to go through both of these
in the slideshow. And so, these technologies have become so good in recent times that there
they can be found anywhere in many different applications for example in you can see in
Google photos or any like iOS photo apps that you can now take a picture and remove anything
that you don't want in the photo like you can remove noise or you can even edit photos
in any way you want while keeping the main subject intact. And then you also have various
applications like text to image generation such as mid-journey that I mentioned earlier.
So, they are also so good that you can create art in any style for any like complexity any
level of detail using just a textual prompt. And so, all of these are like very high quality
like highly advanced technologies that are being used in our day-to-day lives. So, lot
of engineering has gone into this and we will try to understand that. And so, it's kind
of a similar story in text generation also but one thing that I want to highlight here
is that it's not perfect here nothing. So, all the technologies that we have right now
they also have their challenges. For example, one thing that we are showing that by using
CADGEPD or any of these kind of systems or any image generation systems initially they
might seem perfect but there are always some shortcomings that we are still trying to address.
So, all of these even though they are such advanced and like they might seem like match
your technologies they still have a lot of gaps that we still are trying to and want
to cover. So, for example, you can see like in reasoning and in mathematical reasoning
or in following instructions or like when to listen to a human how to argue with a human
all those kind of in all those kind of settings the LLMs don't really understand what to do
what value system to follow. So, with that with the instruction covered now let's get
into the specifics of image generation models and how we got from like initial GAN architectures
to something that are so useful today right. So, this is what so you might have come across
this basic architecture of how a generative adversarial network or GANs look like. So,
this was the original architecture that was proposed and it simply kind of gave a recipe
of how we can train image generation networks without going much into the details. So, here
you can see that you have one generator which tries to create new images from random noise.
So, this is like a fake image generator you can think of it like that. So, image that
is not coming in from some data set and then you have another channel which is a real image
possibly taken from some web source or some camera taken photo and you have a discriminator
network which tries to distinguish between these two photos and this is the whole learning
pipeline and you can think of how you can train this is for the generator the goal is
to create images that the discriminator will not be able to distinguish and the role of
the discriminator is to understand like which one is the real image and which one is the
generated creator image and you can see this as a minimax game which is also the loss function
that we optimize for training these models. So, what you are doing is so the generator
G and the discriminator D are kind of competing each other. So, that's why it's called the
minimax game. So, their objectives are opposing and because they are opposing you can take
like you can once you start optimizing them they will start going towards the solution
which is better for both of these networks right and the loss function can be written
in two parts. So, one is for the like this full thing can be seen as the loss function
for the discriminator where there are two components one is the data component. So, samples coming
in from the actual real data and the second part is so you can see like the Z is sampled
from a probability distribution. So, this is where this random noise distribution is
coming in. So, in the second part you are trying to for the discriminator you are trying
to make sure that the discriminator identifies it as a fake image right and so that is how
the discriminator will see this loss function but the generator will see the loss function
slightly differently. It does not look at the real images in this context. So, it just
looks at the second part because that is where the G function is involved and here it tries
to see whether the discriminator loss is or the discriminator score is minimized. So,
it is trying to make sure that discriminator is not able to understand that it is a fake
image. So, that is how this min max game is created and in this you can think of all of
these things like d theta and g phi the discriminator generator network are all any kind of neural
networks that can take in a certain input dimension. So, here example it is random noise and gives
out some output dimension right. So, it can be a simple feed for a neural network which
just matches the dimension at the input and output. So, this was this is what the original
paper proposed and as we saw earlier the image quality like it was able to create image but
it is not perfect. So, people had to come up with better solutions right. So, this is
basically how as I explained how this optimization works and so, for training the discriminator
you have the full loss function and you are kind of trying to optimize the parameters
of the discriminator and this is the second component which is which is only needed for
the generator training and you can see like this using this you are trying to optimize
the weights only of the generator right. But, this approach was not perfect while this gave
like a starting point but and this was one of the first networks which was able to create
images that was somewhat sensible but it had many problems. So, like the first problem
that become very noticeable was oscillations between generator and discriminator right.
So, if you look at the original diagram. So, these two networks are kind of computing
each other. So, if you do not have a very strong discriminator then the generator can
easily full the discriminator and the discriminator will kind of keep chasing the generator around
right and even if an ideal setting it can happen that the model goes to a degenerate
solution where it is just kind of like in each iteration of discriminator and generator
optimization it just flips around. So, you have the generator getting better in one iteration
and in the next iteration the discriminator getting better right but it is not really
getting to a like finding a good solution. So, that can happen and that is what is called
the oscillation problem. Then there can be a mode collapse problem. So, what can happen
here the generator can sometimes just find one particular type of images that it continues
to generate and that image can be noise as well and somehow if the discriminator fails
to identify that image properly. So, the discriminator will be kind of like suck at accuracy 0 or
100% and the generator will be stuck just generating that kind of images. So, this is
what is called mode collapse. So, that is basically in the space of all images you find
one mode and you just are stuck there. So, that is why it is called mode collapse and
there can be other problems also. So, if the networks are not well balanced or the training
is not stable for example, if the discriminator is too strong then the gradient for the generator
will just vanish because the discriminator will give perfectly classify the all the real
and fake images. So, the generator will not see any gradient coming through the discriminator.
So, this is also another problem and the other scenario might also happen on the discriminator
is we the generator can produce non-realistic images even though it does not look like image
it can still fool the discriminator very easily. So, the main thing that you are noticing here
is there are lot of stability problems that were there with the original gain architecture
and also it was not able to create very high fidelity images that we might want to from
these ones. So, these are kind of some example outputs from the original models and as you
can see the top two are rather simplistic images. So, it was able to create MNIST visit
because it is not a very complex scene. Similarly, for face images it is just a phase that it
had to generate and there was not much diversity in the faces data sets. So, there also it
was able to learn something sensible. But when it comes to these two settings like the
setting C and D, these were based on the C4 data set where you have more complex images,
complex scenes and that is where the original gain totally collapsed. It was not able to
learn very good thing and you can see like it is very heavy mixture of different kinds
of suppressants and you cannot make out what the object is. So, the first kind of big breakthrough
that happened in this space was through the DCGAN architecture and the key thing of the
DCGAN architecture was that instead of the originally proposed neural networks for the
generator and the discriminator functions, DCGAN proposed that you should use CNNs because
it was well understood that CNNs are the kind of networks that are good at processing images
because of their inductive biases of how they process local regions and then try to gather
global features through Pune. So, this paper proposed that what you can do is you can have
two CNNs, one for the generator and one for the discriminator and that will help you process
images and get like extract both global and local features very easily. And they removed
all the fully connected layers and they also like did some training optimization through
batch normalization and all of these things together kind of lead to significant improvement
in the image qualities that were generated. So, now when it comes to CNNs, the traditional
CNN that you might have seen is how you process input image and find the output vector or
output score. So, that is the traditional structural flow of image like you start processing
an image and go by 3 by 3 or 5 by 5 kernels and process them down to a smaller sized vector.
So, it usually does a dimension reduction and that works okay for the discriminator because
the input of the discriminator is an image and you are trying to find the score out of
it. So, that perfectly fills the discriminator network. But the problem appears in the generator
network where you have to start from a random vector as you saw in the original GAN architecture.
You have to start from a random vector and you have to reach like an actual image dimension.
So, which can be say a 64 cross 64 image with three channels if it is an RGB image. So,
how to do that? So, they came up with a novel solution called fractional striding or a transpose
convolution which is kind of the reverse process of what the convolution does. So, this is
what a normal convolution kernel looks like for you and the all the normal CNN networks
for say image classification use this. And here what you see is that for the image you
kind of slide around 5 by 5 or any kind of size kernel over that image and you get scores
for each of the cells. And if you notice if you don't have this padding, what you will
get? You will get a smaller image. So, this will be more clear. So, in this case you have
a stride 1. So, it's just moving one box at a time. So, that's why you also have a padding.
So, you are seeing an image output that is the same dimension as the input. But let's
you make the stride 2. So, you are kind of moving the kernel faster over the image. So,
you are jumping one cell in between. So, then you can see if you start with a 5 by 5 or
6 by 6 image, you end up in a 3 cross 3 image. So, you kind of have the dimension of the
image. So, this is what happens with stride. So, if you increase stride by something, your
image kind of becomes smaller and smaller by that factor. So, now what you can think
of? You just see the inverse process of this. So, what you did earlier, you were jumping
pixels. So, if you had processed say the first pixel in the first kernel, you will skip the
in between and go to the next one. So, just to invert the process, what you can do is
you can wait in between. So, essentially how is that achieved? You take the original image
and you kind of put empty spaces in between. So, this is same as padding as you do like
empty cells, which you can assign like a zero score or a nearest neighbor score or any kind
of heuristic you can apply there. But the main idea is that you kind of put the actual
image pixels further apart. And that is what is called a fractional stride because within
each move, you are not going to the next pixel, but rather you are going to the next pixel
into three moves or two moves or three moves. So, that's why it becomes like a fractional
stride. And if you have some image of the three cross three, your output would become
larger. So, this is the main idea behind how to start from a smaller dimensional vector
and actually reaching a larger sized image matrix, which has to be like a larger kind
of a tensor structure, say 64 cross 64 cross three. So, those optimization kind of figuring
out how to run convolution in the opposite directions was to create images and then using
convolutional networks for both the generator and discriminator significantly moved the
needle ads. So, if you see in these images, you can actually start to make out very like
proper shapes. So, for example, these are bad images and you can clearly make out that,
okay, this is one consistent photo of a bit, which has some patterns or some colors and
most of the scenes are also like somewhat complex. You can see make out multiple objects.
So, if there is a window, there is a bed. So, this was not possible in the previous architecture,
but was now possible to create, right? But even in this generation, if you see why the
objects are becoming clearer, it was still not perfect as what a image or what a human
would consider as a real good quality image. So, some more improvements are required. So,
the next kind of big step that happened in this space is something called progressive
gas. So, what was observed in the previous models is that you were trying to generate
the image in one shot. So, you have some random noises input for the generator and you try
to go to the image by just going through one network and there is one optimization being
done at the final thing, final image, right? So, what this paper proposed is instead of
going to the higher dimension that you are targeting for, for example, say 64 cross 64,
how do you, what happens if you go through it step by step? So, instead of going jumping
to 64, what if you first created a 16 by 16 image, then 32 cross 32. So, that way you
can think of you first, I did the image, what the image should contain and then kind of you
are adding more and more details to that image as you are going to higher and higher resolutions.
So, this is what is why it is called progressive gas, where you are kind of like growing the
generator and discriminator in size throughout the training process. So, how do you achieve
this? So, basically you train the network step by step to generate image at every resolution.
Right? So, for example, you can start at the very minimum size, so which is 4 cross 4,
you first start training the model, the generator and the discriminator both for that dimension
and once the model stabilizes there like your loss is kind of saturated, then you go ahead
and add some new components. So, as now the training process starts happening at 8 cross
8. So, what this does is that it does not load the model to learn all the feature complexities
or like the processing that request to happen within the generator in a single go. So, it
can happen step by step in multiple phase training process and what was observed in this paper
that using this process you can go to a much larger dimension like 1,024 cross 1,024 pixel
which is like what you generally use. So, we usually take photos around the resolution
of 1,000 to 4,000 pixels with an height and we are able to for the first time reach this
dimension through a GAN generation process and the earlier bound were like 32 cross 32
or 64 cross 64. So, this was like a significant jump in improvement. Right? So, how was this
like achieved technically? So, you can imagine like you can just do the training and start
adding layers to the process, but it does not work that well if you just do that blindly.
So, there are few things that this paper did. So, the initial, so the phase 2 and 3 that
I explained. So, basically you start with phase 1 and phase 2 and 3 is where you kind
of grow the process and that is what is shown here. Just suppose you are at this stage,
so some training has happened and you are kind of at this stage where you have a 16
cross 16 dimension output on both sides and you want to take it to like 32 cross 32. So,
if you just slap in the intermediate layer of say the deconvolution and convolution to
32 dimension, it will not work because this layer will be random and the model will not
be able to train again. So, like this initial part of the network is trained, but the intermediate
layer is random way. So, what will happen is that the full model will almost like start
training from beginning again. So, what the paper proposed is that you can kind of slowly
move from the previous network to the next network. So, you do this by creating a routing
layer. So, for example, you have this original 2 RGB which is the 1 cross 1 convolution path
which is giving you the 16 cross 16 image. You take that as it is and you do some, so
you have this 2X which is nearest neighbor filtering. So, you just take this 16 cross
16 image and with a very basic interpolation you make it 32 cross 32. So, that will at
least look like image and to that you add this output of the 32 cross 32 pipeline which
is somewhat noise and somewhat image and which is what you want to train. And you start with
the alpha value of 0. So, what will happen? The network will first see only this bypass
and once you start training and start increasing the alpha magnitude, the model will start
seeing this like secondary path and it will start to train this. And as you like finally
settle on alpha equals to 1 through training, you can then throw out this 2 RGB path and
you can finally get to the actual larger network. And you can keep repeating this process as
much as you want. So, you can go to like 10242048 or even 4K images using this process. So,
this solves a lot of problems that were kind of distilled from the original model. So,
the original model had the problems of mode collapse and everything. But since this architecture
like beyond using the CNN this architecture kind of showed how you can learn the complexities
in step instead of trying to learn them together. And this was what was the reason for the original
models mode collapse. So, because you are trying to learn a very complex distribution
at one go, that's why it was always like converging to or collapsing to one particular
kind of images or random noise. But if you kind of do this training progressively as
this paper did, you can see that it is able to learn this distribution of multiple modalities
very nicely. So, this problem of mode collapse was kind of gone and that helped in increasing
the fidelity significantly. And as you can see from this again, this was like a significantly
large jump and you can actually like so these are 1024 cross 1024 dimensional images and
you can make out the details very easily. So, now another so that was kind of the progression
of GAN and GAN actually was a very unstable architecture and it took a lot of effort like
say five, six years worth of effort to come to like come from the original GAN architecture
to the final GAN architecture that we saw. So, GAN always have this stability problem
and even with the newer architectures, if you increase the complexity or if you go to
a new domain for doing image generation. So, for example, you want to do medical image
generation, a lot of tuning again comes back into the picture because the GAN models do
not work that well out of the box because of their instability and we always need to
start with a lot of hyper parameter tuning and adjustment of the architecture. So, another
architecture which kind of solved that problem is known as VQVA. So, this was not a GAN based
model but had a similar idea key. You start from a noise and come back to an image but
this architecture was much more stable compared to the GAN architectures just in two generations.
So, VQVA was the original architecture and after that they came up with VQVA too which
was like almost at the final stage of what GAN was able to achieve. So, what does this
architecture do is, so from the name you can understand that this is kind of expanded
out in an autoencoder fashion. So, you have a encoder network which takes in any image.
It goes through a CNN and you get a representation and you are training a decoder network to
take the representation. So, if you forget about the intermediate layer, you just take
that representation and try to decode that. So, what this essentially doing like what
essentially autoencoder does is that you try to learn a bottleneck or a intermediate representation
which is a low dimensional representation of the original image space. And what this
paper is essentially doing is kind of making use of that fact you can do that. So, this
was the original autoencoder architecture but if you just take an autoencoder architecture
you still cannot generate an image. So, you will have this intermediate representation
from the encoder but how do you, so at inference time how do you get a new representation for
creating a new image, right? So, you might have a text or something based on which you
want to create an image or you might just want to sample a new image. So, you cannot
do that if you just have autoencoder architecture. So, that's where the VAE or variational autoencoder
architecture comes in and so that's a older like that's a older existing architecture.
What this paper specifically proposed is something called vector quantize variational autoencoder.
So, it kind of combines two things one is the idea of variational autoencoder and the
second is quantization, right? So, first of all what variational autoencoder will do is
instead of going from the like representation directly it tries to learn a distribution
of representation instead in between, right? So, given an image you try to figure out what
is the latent representation in an intermediate space. So, if you have that then you can start
sampling, right? So, that's how the intermediate representation or intermediate distribution
helps. So, that is where the variational part comes in and then you have the vector quantization
part and why you do this is in traditional autoencoders or variational autoencoders the
distribution, the nature of the distribution is actually rather simple. So, you will use
something like a Gaussian distribution which only has a single modality. Now, if you put
so, instead of that if you use a vector quantize set up what will happen all of these embeddings
that you have in the quantize dictionary the vector which is called the code book are independent
to be learned that you kind of move away from the like the Gaussian assumption or the normal
distribution assumption also. So, that's why this kind of performs very nicely. So, since
you have this code book it kind of allows you to learn independent highly like they
have like immense amount of freedom to choose what this vector is. So, the network can do
that and because of that this model can learn like very high quality intermediate distribution
which is which does not have to like conform to any existing distribution structure like
any traditional distribution structure. So, how did the training work then? So, the loss
function was quite linear but also simple. So, it just had 3 components that you kind
of intuitively need to do. So, the first thing obviously is a reconstruction loss. So, what
reconstruction does is you have some representation as the input you want the decoder to be able
to convert that input to an image. So, this is almost like the generator thing that you
do like almost like the generator network. So, by doing this you are ensuring that you
have a decoder network which given an embedding of something coming or sample from somewhere
would be able to create a image or draw image. So, this is the first part but that just solves
one part of the problem. So, you also need to figure out the right space for the representation
and also the right code book. So, that is what is done in the next two steps. So, the
first step is kind of say that whatever code book you have your embedding should come close
to this code book. So, this you will have access to this code book during the inference
process. So, you want the encodings that you have from some existing images during the
training time should fall close to the code book. So, that is what is done here. So, if
you just forget about the sd term it is z of ex minus e. So, you are kind of minimizing
the distance between the embedding and some chosen code from that code book. And the stop
gradient comes in to help because then you will just optimize for the embedding. So,
the gradient will only flow to the encoder network and not will not update the code book
in this part. And the second or the third term here is kind of doing the opposite thing.
So, here you do a stop gradient on the embedding side. So, here what you are saying, okay,
I have an image embedding. Now, bring my code book closer to the image embedding. So, you
are kind of allowing the network to move both of these things together closer together so
that there is less fluctuation during training. So, this both of these loss function terms
kind of stabilizes the training process in terms of what encoding you are getting from
the network, right? Otherwise, it can fluctuate a lot because your initial embedding space
would be very random, right? And another detail here that is important is how to come up with
this individual codes. So, that is very simple. So, you just encode a given input image say
is what we are calling Xi or Ej and you just find out which is the nearest vector within
this code book. So, suppose you have one million code vectors within this code book and you
just find out the one nearest embedding and that is sufficient for like training this
network, right? So, you can make this code book as large as possible, as big as possible
so that will increase your parameter size of the network, but it will not increase the
latency because the lookup is kind of fixed time using various optimizations that you
can do for vector search, right? So, that is how you train the like that is how the original
VQVA idea looked like and you can train this using this loss function, but this still had
some shortcomings. It was able to get to like really good quality pictures, but there was
still some shortcomings because of this fixed CNN network as we saw in the progressive scan
also. Having a single network to come like come and go from the embedding level to the
final image is slightly difficult. So, this paper also kind of came up with a similar
idea where you try to learn a layered process of generating the image. So, what it allows
you to do first to come up with lower level features and also like learn those lower level
features and from there to expand out the actual details within the image, right? So,
this is what was called the VQVA to architecture and what did what this did is it like at the
beginning itself, it initialized several layers of hierarchy from the image. So, if you see
how the image was processed here through a single block of encoder, instead of that,
you just imagine that it goes through multiple layers of encodings, right? So, first you
will do a encoding, you will go to a feature map which is much larger in size because it's
a CNN and then if you add another layer of CNN that feature map will reduce slightly in
size. So, that will be like a more high level or abstract representation of the image, but
also like it will be more compressed, right? So, that is what is like happening exactly
here. So, you have multiple levels of encoder and you supervise at every layer of the representation
or like some layers of the representation even if not all, right? And what you do for
training is that now once you have that, you try to train the VQVA network at every stage,
right? So, you have this like bigger feature map, you go there from the, through the quantization
process and you train that quantization process to go back to a decoder to the actual image.
You add another layer of encoder, you get a lower, like a higher level representation
which is smaller in size and then you go through the, go through another VQVA quantizer and
get something back, right? So, what this is giving you, like it will give you multiple
levels of code books quantizations, which kind of have a hierarchical structure. So,
you can always first start with a higher level VQ like quantization during sampling, from
that figure out what is the lower level quantization and from there you can go to the reconstruction.
And this is what the sampling process on the right here does is once you have trained this
network, you can just throw away the encoder that is not required anymore and you can fit
another network to go through this hierarchy. So, it basically starts by sampling from the
highest level of representation and step by step figures out what is the next level of
representation. And this kind of give you a hierarchical decoding process which finally
goes to a very high quality high fidelity image and this network was able to create images
which are, which are like much more detailed and could handle much more complexities in
the images, right? So, as you can see, this is what the different levels of hierarchy
look like, like as you decoded them. And as you can see, like the higher level feature
we will have will kind of dictate what is the object and what is the scene content.
And as you go through the layers of the hierarchy, it will add more and more detail like the
cares and the leaves in the background, right? So, what this architecture kind of did is
first of all, it allowed you a lot of flexibility in the latent space by having that code book.
So, now you are not restricted to say something like a guardian representation which was often,
which can often create bloody images but not like very highly detailed images. So, these
network was for the first time able to get like a lot of detail into the generated images
and this paper also proposed a novel loss function that was able to train this VQVI architecture
in a very efficient and optimal manner, right? So, this, yeah, so with this I will kind of
end the image part, like the imagination part and this was around 19, 2020 and this kind
of became like the final point of imagination through GAN or VAE kind of architectures.
After this also, many different GAN models are proposed but beyond this, a new architecture
kind of came into picture which is called diffusion models and that is what is used nowadays.
And diffusion models also allows you a lot of flexibility and it's kind of similar to
theoretical decoding that you learn during the process. So, I will not cover that but
you can go check out like the recent advancement in that field also, right? And other than
the, just other, like other than the architectures that we are developing here, there are other
interesting research questions also which was kind of solved fairly. So, there are a
lot of metrics developed because when you are going to such high quality images, standard
error metrics or loss functions stop working very well. Like for example, if you have mean
squared error, that can understand the difference between a real image and a fake image when
the difference is large. But if the images are very close, they will not be able to detect
like the smaller discrepancies that are there in the generated images. So, like later on
metrics like FID and inception scores, these things are proposed. So, these are model based
metrics which were able to understand how, what was the fidelity level of the images,
how detailed were the images, all these things. So, there are questions like this that were
also simultaneously solved. There are architectural questions that were solved, like system side
architectural questions that were solved. So, all of these things also happened together
and this kind of led to the final like the high quality image generator that we see today.
So, okay. So, now we will move on to the like the large language generation section and this
also has kind of become important in the last like six, seven years with the evolution of
creativity and this kind of models and the applications of those models that we are seeing
now like almost in every application. Right. And this is, this also went through kind of
a similar trajectory of how you took the original architecture or original idea of language modeling
that was present, the kids back and how it came to the stage that we have today. Right.
So, what are elements basically? So, large language models are simply models that can
generate language and can talk to humans in a way. Right. So, if you have a very perfect
language model, you can make it to generate anything. Right. And this technology has recently
become very popular and very successful and with models like cloud, productivity, Gemini,
Lama, like various applications have also popular and it's like known to almost everyone
who are not working in this domain also. Right. But coming to like, coming to this recent
state of LLMs was a much more mixed process of development. Like lot of improvements happened
in many different spaces that we are seeing this. So, it was not just an architectural
improvement here. So, a lot of other things also needed to improve to kind of get to where
so this was slightly more complex than the landscape of image generation. So, we'll look
at a few of these challenges that research was facing and how did they come to solve
those problems. Right. So, I will first quickly define like what the basic language modeling
are like looked like initially before say 2018, 2019 and like what was the transition
that happened after that. Right. So, the idea of language model was very old. So, it started
around 1950s and 1980s popular building statistical language models based on say n-grams or other
hand designed features. And the goal was to basically fit a distribution to any human
language. Right. So, it didn't have any fancy goal back then. We are just trying to learn
a parametric model that can say given a context what is the next possible probable word. Right.
And so, that can be just seen mathematically as if you have a context like this, you are
trying to come up with the next token in a way or like the next character in the text
sequence. Right. And this was important because if you have a parametric model like this,
you can do a lot of things like you can of course, you can generate new text and you
can also do certain statistical studies of these models. You can understand how distribution
varies between various languages and within even within a language how the like what is
the distribution of various word sentences and all of these things. Right. So, it had
some linguistic importance. And so, the original kind of original effort towards building these
language models are focused first on n-grams before MLPs or neural networks. Then there
are a lot of neural network based language models which was still trying to kind of model
these kind of like or trying to approximate these kind of a function. But they are still
like not as powerful because there are a lot of assumptions that were going into the picture.
Like for n-grams, you were not able to fit very long input sequences. You were truncating
them off at say 2-gram or 3-grams. So, it cannot like generate as complex a model and
it was also tabularized in a way. So, you were not fitting any neural network at that point.
But then with MLPs, you tried fitting ANNs or what like ANNs to this to learn this n-gram
model. But there also, you were having challenges because you can fit again a fixed length context
window even though that was bigger than a statistical n-gram model that was still limited.
And then what to make was, so it was exploiting this idea of language modeling to learn representations
or vector representations for these words or sentences. So, this is like one of the biggest
applications that we are still able to exploit. So, all of these kind of came before and these
were seen as a tool for solving other problems but were never like directly usable. And one
of the major reason was because like this language itself is very complex, but the underlying
models that we are using either statistical or a simple neural network were not complex
enough to learn the distribution. But after that, we started seeing complex networks like
ANNs, LSTMs, or transformers. So, the key thing that changed between this and this is
that your context window became infinite almost. So, now you are able to factorize the model
language models as by just simple change rule of probability and there is no approximation
that is happening in this factorization. So, that gives a lot of power to these models.
So, one of the important key things of human language is that you can have very long conversations
and can remember things from like past situations. Hey, so that is what these like long factorizations
can allow and that is what became possible with these kind of models that they were able
to capture very long context and our systems like GPUs and servers have become powerful
enough to handle these kind of highly complex models. So, this is what a standard like a
block diagram of this model should look like. So, you have input context of some n number
of words and this can be any length in modern architectures and you are trying to just predict
the next word that you can have. And how do you train this is something called maximum
likelihood estimate. So, what you are trying to see you if you come up with the distribution
of the next word from the network say by applying a softmax over a set of logits then you can
just see what is the probability of the ground truth token that I have in my dataset and
just focus on maximizing that. So, this is what is traditionally known as maximum likelihood
estimate finding the maximum likelihood estimate and also called as the cross-entropy loss
in general in the natural language literature. And so, this is like the standard training
procedure that is still being followed in all of the networks. So, this is in slight contrast
to what you saw in the image generation. So, there you saw that the loss function also
needed to evolve but here the key loss function for training the raw language model has almost
remained the same. It is still this probability of the ground truth token that you are trying
to maximize. And once you have trained this network inference is also very simple you
can just pass in the context get the distribution for the next token take the max or sample
from it and you can look through it and you can start generating languages. And also the
intermediate vectors that you get from such models again can be used as a representation
for the text and that is also used in many different applications like if you have any
sort of classifiers or recommendation systems that you see use these sort of embeddings
as features for doing classification and stuff. So, now with the like so basically you had
the loss function in place from long back. So, that cross-entropy loss function was used
even if you go back like 10 years from now that loss function was still being used for
training RNNs and LSTM based language models. But what kind of change in these factors where
lots of developments in other areas. So, one of the key area of implement that was necessary
was the tokenizer. So, if you see in the original architecture I kind of intuitively gave the
input context as like by splitting them into words as the input to the network. So, that
is where the sequence is coming from. And if you think about this, this works if you
don't have a language where say the character space is there or if you have word switcher
very common. But if you have word switcher complex for example long words like tokenizer
then you have either have to make the vocab size very large or you have to somehow figure
out like how to handle these words. Otherwise what will happen is this will just be treated
as unseen words and you will have like a fixed representation for each of these unseen words.
So, that is not very good for training neural network models you want to have representation
for everything that is part of your network. So, to solve that problem one intuitive approach
is that you start representing each character as a token. So, then what you can do is you
can break this input sequence simply just in terms of character instead of words. So,
that will take care of having no out of distribution or out of vocab token. But the problem that
it creates is that it will make the sequences very long and the modern architectures like
transformers are kind of quadratically dependent on the like have quadratic time complexity
on the sequence length. So, if you make the sequence length by having characters say five
times longer your model training time and inference time will become almost 25 times
longer. So, that is prohibitive. So, we needed some other solutions. So, that is where this
idea of tokenizer comes in and like some improvements like key improvements in tokenizer kind of
enable the modern models to process any kind of words any novel words in the context.
So, the main idea is that you have full words which can go out of vocab because you cannot
store all possible words of a language. There can be millions of words possible and if you
try to store so many things the complexity of the embedding there would be very large
and on the other hand you have the characters. Characters will make your sequence length
very long. So, you need a middle ground between them and that is where ideas like subwords
and byte pairs came in and which essentially almost solved this problem.
So, what the idea of byte pair encoding or a subword tokenization is that if you have
a text corpus you will see some like groups of characters which are sometimes words or
sometimes can be subwords that appear very frequently. For example, here you can see
the pair of characters or like the PO is coming very frequently in the vocab then you also
have like the KE as a pattern that is repeating in the vocab. So, what byte pair encoding
does is that it essentially figures out all such patterns that occur frequently in the
dataset and just creates a vocab out of that. Now, you can intuitively think that what kind
of token patterns that will be most frequently seen. So, obviously very common words like
the me, I, your. So, all of all these kinds of words will be very frequently seen in a
corpus. So, this would automatically be captured by this tokenization process. So, BPA kind
of includes the most frequent words by default and it will also have certain constituent
subwords that would help you to later reconstruct bigger words that you have not seen before.
So, that allows you to avoid the out of vocab problem when you don't have not seen the vocab
during printing data and it also kind of allows you to handle that if there is some word like
let's say for index. So, if you let's say this is a word that is coming in from some
specific domain for which you have not even seen the intermediate patterns that exist
within that word. So, the BPA tokenizer still contains the individual character and will
tokenize any unseen words by at least at a character level. So, it can start from full
words then to subwords if it has not seen that and if it's a very novel word that it
has like not even seen the patterns within it, it will just break it down to all characters
and it will always allow the transformer model or the language model to have a unique representation
for those. So, and how is this built is essentially you start with, so you first start with the
array of all the characters that you want to cover. So, this is for example the character
essentially English alphabet or any other language alphabet and then you start figuring
out what are the most common patterns that you want to add to the vocab. So, if you have
the first character, if you first have the characters in your list of vocab, then what
you can do, you can start looking at pairs of these characters and see which ones are
next most frequent in the dataset and then you can repeat the process to formulate bigger
and bigger patterns and then you will also have words and subwords all included in the
vocab and you can stop at some vocab size V so that you have the most common things
up until that point included in the vocab and anything that is beyond that will be reconstructed
using the tokenization mechanism. So, basically this BP tokenizer or subword tokenization
kind of solved a big problem that was lingering for like almost a decade but this didn't solve
all like many other problems also which are still kind of existing problems and people
are trying to come up with like intelligent solutions. So, one is that you have to keep
in mind which languages you want to support and if you build a tokenizer based on say
English corpus or even a mixed language corpus, you may miss out certain languages during
the inference time. So, this always becomes a tradeoff to which languages you are using,
which corpus you are using for building this corpus will dictate performance of uncertain
languages at the inference time. So, this is a very important thing to keep in mind and
then there is also inference latency that you have to consider. So, suppose you start
like build a tokenizer vocab of size 40,000 tokens then your vocab might not be large
enough that your some of the sequences are becoming very long. So, your inference latency
might still be high but if you start in increasing the tokenizer vocab size then your inference
latency will go down but you might start seeing some very unique long words which are not
very frequent in the training set. So, in that case you might have to figure out how
to get good representation for them. So, there are still some challenges in these approaches
too and then there is one interesting challenge that as newer and newer governments are being
covered for example, say if you want to include code generation, if you want to do mathematical
reasoning. So, the kind of tokens or words that you see in those domains may not be covered
in the tokenizer that you have built in now. So, that becomes another challenge as to how
to cover like newer domains, what sort of tokenizers to build in the specific domains
that also is a interesting challenge and then recently there have been introduction of image
and speech in transformer models. So, people are trying to build tokenizers for this kind
of data also where you can think of certain basis patterns that can exist in the image
or speech vectors would be useful as entity within the tokenizer. So, that was the tokenizer
story and so another problem that this language model evolution was kind of facing is how
to evaluate these models. So, the natural loss function that is used which I showed earlier
it is basically the log probability of this probability function. So, you are always optimizing
for this thing right. So, this is your loss function in a way and you can observe whether
this particular metric is improving as you are training your models. So, this naturally
becomes a metric but what people noticed is that this is not a perfect evaluation metric
for the actual downstream task. So, traditionally this is known as perplexity. So, perplexity
is nothing but the two to the power the cross entropy loss with some normalization factor
and this was good for understanding whether the training process of a language model is
going well. So, for example, if you want to do cross validation you can do it using this
metric but this was not indicative of any downstream performance that you might want
to understand. So, if you have say accuracy on a sentiment classification benchmark or
accuracy on a mathematical reasoning task in a long generation context right. So, that
will not be covered by will not be understood by a metric like this. So, people tried to
find out which sort of metric you can design for those. So, that is also a big area of
research. So, one like interesting thing that I would want to comment here is if you see
like the initial evolution of language models from say LST based models RNN based models
to start of the GPT evolution which is GPT 2. So, you can see like there are significant
drops in the perplexity metric right. So, it was noticeable but as soon as you started
going beyond 29 into the more recent models see how the improvement in your perplexity
has kind of decayed down to a few points. So, what is happening here is as you cross
this GPT 2 model this like the language generation became very good. So, after that point you
will not see much change in the actual distribution that this language model is creating but there
would be very nuanced differences between the distributions from say GPT 2 to GPT 2 fine
tuned which will make a big difference in the downstream task or the quality of the generations
right. So, that is what the test perplexity was failing to cover and why we needed this
evaluation metrics right. So, to solve this what people did is they came up with something
called leaderboard based evaluations. So, in this leaderboard based evaluations you have
multiple tasks that are kind of hidden from the researcher. So, there are in the background
there are tasks like certain generation quality arithmetic reasoning logical reasoning as
I have shown in this kind of on the right figure. So, these are the individual tasks
and that is what you are kind of trying to see how these models perform on. So, if you
have a new model for example GPT 4.01 what you do is you would take that model and run
the forms that is there in the leaderboard or the task that is there in the leaderboard
and you would submit them here and someone then would come like some evaluated human
evaluator would come and see whether the outputs from this new model was any better than the
older models. However, they are not allowed to see which model it was. So, you are kind
of doing a blind anonymized comparison between models. So, this is basically a human mediated
voting based evaluation mechanism which allows you to understand downstream performance of
these newer and newer models right and goes much beyond perplexity. And as you can see
with the new models that are coming up. So, this is what has become a challenge and what
this lot of modern language model papers are kind of trying to solve is if you propose
a new model for example GPT 4.0 you can see it kind of improved on algebraic reasoning
but at the same time just lost all its performance on logical reasoning and numeric common sense
right. So, this always keeps happening and this is what we are trying to like the research
community is now trying to figure out how to align or like fix these language models
in a way that they perform or understand all the requirements of human applications that
might we might have. So, now we will look at one final thing which is the data aspect
of language model 20. So, like we have gone through several aspects right now. So, we
looked at evaluation matrix we looked at the pre-training loss function and we also looked
at the like the organization approach. So, with all of this also there is still like
lot of gaps to close. So, what researchers in mainly in open AI and sort of like anthropic
notice is that as you increase the size of the training data that kind of gives non-linear
improvements in your downstream task. So, this is what we came to know as emergence that
as you are increasing the size of your training data set size and the size of your model the
performance on the downstream task or the evaluation matrix that we showed earlier it would just
go up exponentially right. So, that is where the requirement to understand and improve pre-training
data became very important. So, the original models like the BERT or the GPT2 models were
trained on very clean purpose that we had access to from earlier like corpus that was
built for this kind of purposes before. So, that usually included book corpus or Wikipedia
which usually contain like very clean text. But now as this like after more and more pre-training
data came into the picture that how do you increase say how do you go from a billion
token for pre-training to a trillion token corpus that becomes challenging. So, now you
cannot do like even if you crawl Wikipedia you will not have that much data. So, what
people started doing they started crawling the web as it is right. So, now when you start
crawling the web a lot of noisy data start coming into picture. So, as you can see in
this example like there will be if like this if you are crawling say HTML page. So, you
will get text like this which will have a lot of JavaScript code which will have a lot
of HTML code into the picture and your language model would be trained on that. Then say if
you are looking at PDF it will have certain binary headers that the model will get trained
and trained that. And if you are say having looking at other different domains also say
GitHub Stack Overflow they will start seeing codes. So, as you increase data of course
your scope of learning increase give what which sort of domains you are able to cover
but it also created a problem of unclean data. So, filtering kind of became important and
people started by doing heuristic filtering say if we just filter data based on certain
websites you are else. That is one way to clean things. So, will likely certain websites
which does not give you clean data. So, you started filtering it this way but that also
became prohibitive because after certain scale you will kind of run out of ideas to apply
heuristics and heuristics will always be kind of very strong. So, it will take out a lot
of data. So, at some point you started like not caring about filtering but trying to find
out other approaches as to how to do. And the problem that happened with this that if
you let go of all filter and when you say need to get like 10 trillion token purpose
you included that in the LLM. What will start happening is LLMs will also start generating
uncontrolled generations like this right. So, you will give it some prompt but you will
not know which structure or what kind of output it will give. So, it can look like that way
it can be HTML page it can be anything because that has a finite probability in your language
model. Right and even with the GPT-4 model GPT-3 model that we know now to be so successful
the researchers of OpenAI revealed that the original models were actually not that great
in terms of control. So, for example if you gave a prompt like explain the moon landing
to a six year old it will start generating other questions instead of going to answer.
So as you can see like we had a very strong probabilistic model parametric model for the
distribution of language but we did not know what was like if we sample from it what would
get generated because everything was possible like every other valid generation was possible
from the distribution. Right so that's where this idea of post training came into the picture
because as I said you can go so far with quality filtering and that becomes challenging as
you increase the size of the corpus too much. So, people started looking at not constraining
the corpus for pre training but rather thinking about how we can portray post train or fix
the model itself after it has been pre trained and that is where this concept of alignment
came into picture. So, the first so what alignment tries to do is if you have a raw language
model after training the raw language model on the full pre training corpus you show it
the clean data that you wanted it to generate and that's showing the clean data to the model
is what become the research question key because these are very large language models how do
you show this clean data and what should be the amount of clean data that you show what
should be the approach to training become very challenging right. So, the basic approach
that you can think of and is also still part of this alignment process is you basically
do supervised fine tuning. So, say if you have good answers to questions like explain the
moon landing to a six year old or things that children or like things that user would ask
you give it such a data set of clean samples that would usually be like fifty thousand
or hundred thousand samples and you just do supervised fine tuning of the data set right.
But as you can understand these models have billions of parameters in them and so rich
in knowledge that no matter how much such like how much such corpus you curate it will
not be able to cover all kind of all of this kind of data right all of these kind of domains
within your models knowledge. So, that creates a problem that your supervised fine tuning
might address some problems it will not address all problems and then there is also the problem
that since your models are so over parameterized the model can just remember these data points
right. So, it will not actually align or it will not actually improve its probability
distribution, but it rather remember these samples and would just start to hallucinate
in a desert way that you again have no control over right. So, to solve that what people
did is they both like started looking for solution in the reinforcement learning literature
because what reinforcement learning allows you to do is kind of create samples in like
in in an online process you can always create samples and then somehow process them or grade
them using human evaluators to see which ones to prefer and which ones not to prefer. So,
what this allowed is that you can have two different models or two different generations
from a raw language model you can create multiple examples like A, B, C, D and you can then tell
ask the human to rank these options or which one is the best way to respond to a human
query right. So, this way what you are doing is this so this kind of introduces a exploration
phase which ensures that you are covering the full parameter space or the full knowledge
space of the language model right and based on that you can have you can like get what
is called a preference data. So, for each query you will have multiple generations and
then there would be order between them that generation one was better than generation
two better than generation three and based on that you can create what is called a reward
model. So, this is basically a ranking model or a scoring model which is by look this by
looking at input input query and and the generation would just tell you how good that is so it
will give you a score and then once you have this so you kind of did the first phase of
exploration using this trained reward model you can do another phase of exploration where
you take the reward model and start generating more samples from the language models right
and once you have this generation you will see more and more reward values using the
reward model based on that you can further optimize this language model. So, this kind
of expanded the possibility of how much you can train with the finite amount of data into
a large amount of data by just doing sampling right. So, this kind of covered the ground
of the problems of hallucinations that we had earlier because we do not anymore want
to fine tune on the data directly to just maximize the probability right. So, this is
what was called as RLHF or reinforcement learning human feedback and this is the loss function
that is usually used. So, this is a traditional reinforcement learning loss function where
you have the expectation over some generated samples from your language model and you are
trying to maximize the reward function that you have trained here the reward model and
this is a regularization parameter is that is just saying that when you are doing this
training you should not move too much away from the reference model and just stay close
to that because if you train again based on the reward model too much it can start to
hack the reward model or overfit to the reward model which again would be problematic. So,
this overall function is what is like the traditional mechanism of training using RLHF
and ensured that you are able to move beyond what the SFT was allowing you to do right.
So, another kind of proposal another interesting direction that was developed based on this
RLHF idea is that since the RLHF process was based on this fixed loss function that
we kind of know of and the fixed data set. So, even if you are doing the sampling process
it was found out that this essentially amounts to optimizing a fixed loss function without
doing the sampling. So, you can just do a specific kind of fine tuning which as you can
see it is very different from SFT but it takes into account that what sort of regularization
you are trying to have what sort of reward process like sampling process you are doing
in the RLHF process and it combined that to a single fine tuning process. So, you have
this data set of preferences and you can just optimize this loss function on that preference
data set and that amounts to doing the same thing as the longer RLHF process. So, this
was useful in terms of kind of minimizing the training load and doing it more efficiently.
So, you do not have to do the sampling process but it still does not get a lot of things
perfect. So, there is still so RLHF is still in use. So, there are important things that
you can do in RLHF like you can do credit assignment of intermediate steps in the process
when you are doing reasoning. So, all of these are still being explored but DPO kind of allows
you to do a quick fine tuning once you have a lot of preference data. So, both of these
things have been combined in many follow up papers and just to quickly understand the
loss function what this essentially is doing it is contrasting between the two generations
that you have. So, if your preference data said that for the prompt x or the input x
y w was better than y n what you are essentially doing is that pi theta or the trained model
like the tuned model that you are getting should have a higher probability of y w over
the reference and that gain should be more than the gain in the while like the bad generation.
So, essentially you kind of increase the probability of y w in comparison to y n as it was in the
reference model. So, you are kind of slightly tuning the model to have better probabilities
for the winning solutions. So, that is kind of like all the things that I wanted to discuss.
So, there are a lot of things that we did not discuss here and but are still like interesting
directions to explore. So, there are a lot of system optimizations that have happened
in the like in parallel in the background because of which we are able to do this kind
of training center able to use this kind of models. So, for example, GPT4 or Claude models
are so large in size that you cannot hold them in one GPU or even in four GPUs that
you can have in one system. So, you need thousands of GPUs in a cluster on multiple like multiple
computers to able to be able to host a single instance of say a GPT4 model right. So, there
are a lot of effort went into GPTGP parallelization networking between these nodes to be able to
do these kind of inference where a model is hosted between like a cluster of computers
right. Then there are a lot of improvements made in terms of model parallelization is
if you were to split this model into multiple systems how to do inference like because some
layers are sitting in some of the GPUs and some other layers sitting in some other GPUs.
So, the forward pass becomes different and if you have multiple data points across multiple
nodes that also becomes difficult. So, like to reduce the throughput issues to reduce like
how much communication is done between the nodes a lot of optimizations were required
like for this also right and then we have also seen a lot of effort that has gone towards
lower and mixed precision training and inference because as your model becomes larger and larger
if you want to do say a local hosting or if you want to keep your data private. So, you
might want to host these models in smaller GPUs or smaller systems and they are lower
mixed precision inference because very helpful where instead of operating in the float 32
or 32 bit integer mode you kind of quantize the points down or the parameters down to
something like 4 bit or 8 bit integers right. That way your model size becomes smaller so
you can do inference of a Lama model on a 16 GB single 16 GB GPU also right. So, that
is what it allowed. So, similarly there are other optimizations for attention mechanism.
So, flash attention is like used almost everywhere nowadays. Then there are optimizations then
that came into the libraries also like fighters and TensorFlow and there are other open questions
also. So, lower fine tuning was proposed to allow like smaller to tune this model for
smaller tasks when you don't have much data then there is SLM distillation methods when
you don't want to use the like don't want to give the cost of GPT-4 for a small task
you can distill how to distill that capability of a larger model into a smaller model. All
of these things have been explored and like what you are seeing nowadays in terms of these
usable platforms like GPT-4 cloud is a result of all of these like innovations. So, with
that I will end my talk and thank you. So, if there are any questions I can thank them.
Thank you.
.
Hi. So, for the questions should I access the chat from someone or.
I think you will share the screen sir. Sorry. Okay. I will take it. I will stop sharing.
Thank you.